[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir anatole
collinet makosso premier ministre de la
république du congo est notre invité ce
soir de passage à paris nous parlerons
de la dette de son pays à l'occasion de
la réunion du fmi à laquelle il va
participer et son positionnement
international notamment dans la crise en
ukraine mais aussi de la délinquance qui
frappe le congo brazzaville
le choc et l'émotion au sénégal après l
annonce du décès d'une femme enceinte
non assistés et qui a agonisé pendant
plusieurs heures devant l'hôpital dans
le nord du pays a fait divers qui met la
lumière sur les dysfonctionnements
graves des structures de santé dans le
pays
et nous irons à abidjan pour suivre la
première étape de la tournée africaine
de mme et montréal une exposition qui
présente des oeuvres de 14 femmes
africaines dont le travail pose un
regard singulier sur notre histoire
universelle reportage à suivant
il a été nommé premier ministre de la
république du congo il ya tout juste un
an par le président sassou n'guesso il
est de passage à paris anatole collinet
makosso merci d'être dans le journal de
france 24 vous êtes entre autres à paris
pour cette assemblée générale du fmi
l'occasion pour vous de faire un bilan
vous aviez obtenu 450 millions l'année
dernière mais plus largement quel bilan
faites vous de vos un an à la tête du
pays merci beaucoup madame fatima et
merci de même l'occasion d'être sur ce
plateau un an demain ce sera l'année
d'investiture de monsieur le président
la république ce n'est pas encore de
l'année anniversaire dieu mais mes chers
du gros noms que je suis un mois
avril oui bien sûr douze mois pour le
présent la république 12 mois
d'exécution dans un projet de société
douze mois pour lever les préalables qui
consistait à gérer la crise sanitaire
pour un retour à la vie normale mais
préalable qui consistait à rétablir les
équilibres macro économique parce que
comme vous le savez mes paramètres
étaient au rouge
douze mois pour relancer l'économie pour
mettre en chantier le plan national de
développement qui venait d'être élaborée
voilà ce qu'on peut déjà retenir à ce
stade alors on en parlera de ce plan du
pnd dont 2022 2026
mais par rapport à la dette et en
particulier par rapport à l'aide qu'ils
avaient été accordées 450 millions par
l' effet mis il y avait une condition
c'était une décote de votre dette de 30
% là vous êtes à 6% quels sont vos
objectifs là pour atteindre cette décote
d'abord retenir que en avril 2021 cette
dette est estimée à près de 110 %
aujourd'hui elle est à autour de 80%
vous voyez bien d'efforts qui a été à
94,84 je vais vous dire avec précision
ses 4 24% il faut laisser quelques
marges d'erreur quelques fenêtres oui
oui mais nous sommes autour de 80% il
faut donc voir les efforts qui ont été
accomplis en termes de restructuration
de cette dette et en termes de réformes
qui auront permis effectivement de
réduire la dette de passer d'une
politique de surendettement à une
politique de désendettement vous
paraissez très intéressant justement
parce que vous parliez justement du plan
du du pnd donc 2022 2026 vous aviez dans
vos enfants vos idées ou en tout cas
dans les propositions d'inclure des
partenariats publics privés et des
investissements innovants où en êtes
vous sur cette question précise au
comblement de financement retenu est
justement celui là recourir aux emprunts
concessionnels éviter les emprunts non
concessionnels
privilégier le partenariat public privé
et bien entendu il imaginer des
financements innovants nous y
travaillons et en ce moment nous sommes
sur un programme d'ailleurs qui consiste
à rechercher un certain nombre de
mécanismes de financement mais nous
travaillons aussi au regard des réformes
qui sont entreprises à payer la dette
c'est pourquoi vous voyez les efforts
qui sont accomplis après la
restructuration de la dette et traders
avec blain corps qui était le dernier
trailer qui était hostile à toute
restructuration
cette restructuration est fait
et on peut dire aujourd'hui la dette du
congo est soutenable grâce aux efforts
entrepris par hull où le gouvernement
grâce aux efforts et peut-être à l'aide
de la chine éventuellement les
pourparlers avec la chine se poursuivre
encore mais des efforts ont été
accomplis par notre mécanisme
aujourd'hui oui c'est ce qu'a menées le
fonds monétaire internationale à
reconnaître le caractère soutenable la
dette et à conclure avec nous une
facilité élargie de crédit de 3 ans
d'accord alors parlons de la situation
internationale la guerre que mène la
russie en ukraine votre pays fait partie
de ceux en afrique et n'est pas le seul
à s'être abstenu au moment du vote de
cette résolution aux nations unies qui
condamnait justement cette invasion
expliquez-nous votre vote rapidement
mais simplement rester le fidèle à la
logique qui est la nôtre depuis que le
président denis sassou n'guesso et aux
affaires et privilégie la diplomatie le
dialogue pour la sécurité la stabilité
du continent parce que comme vous le
savez l'afrique est habitué à ces crises
du genre celle qui se passe aujourd'hui
en ukraine on a connu les invasions a
reconnu les les conflits de frontières
on a connu des crises internes et toutes
ces crises qui ont été résolus que par
la diplomatie par le dialogue nous
étions déjà heureux au début de la crise
de voir le président emmanuel macron
anticiper sur la diplomatie éviter l'
escalade en parcourant les capitales
pour prêcher le dialogue pour prêcher le
langage la diplomatie et ce sans que ces
efforts que nous avons voulu consolider
au niveau du continent la position
africaine était une position qui
consistait à éviter la stigmatisation
mais plutôt à encourager la diplomation
encourager le dialogue parce que nous le
savions dès le départ qu'une guerre on
sait quand elle commence on ne sait
jamais quand elle termine donc ça n'a
rien à voir que la chine ne vous a pas
demandé de vous abstenir mais je n'ai
rien à voir vous voulez parler de la
russie certainement n'allonge part de la
ville on sait que le la chine a fait un
lobbying très important sur le continent
africain justement non pas du tout tout
un ris tout et crise au sein du
continent ont été résolus par la
diplomatie par le dialogue et c'est
cette politique que nous mettons
toujours en oeuvre nos pensions que il
était
très risqué d'aller vers des sanctions
économiques parce que l'histoire nous
enseigne que toutes les fois qu'on a
recours aux sanctions économiques pour
condamner un régime c'est le peuple qui
paye le plus lourd tribut maroua censée
consommer justement cette terrible
alimentaires et les répercussions
justement on craint une famine sur le
continent africain qu'est ce que vous
pouvez faire vous allez faire rapidement
pour justement éviter les conséquences
de cette de cette guerre dramatique sur
le compte et c'est ce que nous
entrevoyons déjà parce qu'on pensait que
tels que la situation était conduite
avec les sanctions qui ont été prises
des succès économiques avec le jem en
risque est de contenir de connaître une
crise de la fin une crise de famine et
l'insécurité alimentaire et vous voyez
que tous les pays organisent aujourd'hui
adopté des plans de résidence pour faire
face à cette crise très bien merci
beaucoup monsieur le premier ministre à
anatole collinet makosso d'être venu sur
le journal de l'afrique merci beaucoup
pour cette étape est pour le point que
vous avez fait de vos presque un an à la
tête de la république du groupe merci
beaucoup merci
la ministre allemande des affaires
étrangères était à niamey l'occasion de
rencontrer son homologue nigérien sur
l'action militaire française et
européenne dans la région après
plusieurs semaines de flou diplomatique
le niger est plus claire et ils
demandent un renforcement de
l'intervention européenne sur son sol on
écoute le ministre nigérien des affaires
étrangères
[Musique]
et à danser
ça va
l'impression
d'oublier c'est tout simple
de
ne pas reconnaître la formation semble t
il son
épouse rad
d'après toujours
comment ça va la tenter
[Musique]
en guinée un dialogue autour de la
transition s'est ouvert ce vendredi la
rencontre inaugurait par le colonel
doumbouya le chef de la junte s'est déjà
boycottée par les principaux partis
politiques du pays les précisions de
malik de quitter notre correspondant à
conakry
quelques représentants de partis
politiques de la société civile et des
diplomates accrédités ont répondu à
l'appel de la jambe et se sont rendus ce
vendredi au palais de la présidence
absence très remarquée celle de l'ufdg
de cellou dalein diallo et le rpg arc en
ciel la formation politique d'alpha
condé le président dessus six partis
politiques boycott de la rencontre pour
des raisons différentes pour l'uop
d'egypte le dialogue ne devrait
concerner que la jante les partis
politiques est l'instance en régionale
la cedeao le rpg a conservé demande
d'abord la libération d'alpha condé et
les anciens cadres du régime déchu qui
sont incarcérés pour présumée corruption
malgré tout le colonel mamadou milhac
inauguré la séance s'est voulu
rassembleur
entre nous c'est pourquoi ne jamais
décidé de mettre en place un cadre de
concertation
j'espère que tout le monde va s'y mettre
pour trouver une solution et permettre à
la guinée db dans le concert des nations
et aussi
une solution finale pour qui ce
transition soit la dernière
selon le ministre de l'administration du
territoire ces rencontres devraient
servir à l'élaboration d'une nouvelle
constitution et surtout à organiser
notamment une présidentielle et des
législatives
aucun calendrier n'a pour l'instant
filtré de cette discussion
allons à présent au sénégal où l'émotion
est grande depuis l'annnonce de la mort
de sauna astou la jeune femme enceinte
et qui est morte après avoir agonisé
pendant plusieurs heures devant
l'hôpital qui situé à louga qui ne
l'avait pas pris en charge un drame qui
lève le voile sur les errements du
système de santé sénégalais reportage à
louga de notre correspondant elemento
christ et ses colères règne dans la
maison de sonas tout il ya quelques
jours cette jeune femme enceinte perdait
la vie à l'hôpital public de louga après
avoir demandé en vain une césarienne sa
tante qui à assister à son agonie ne
décolère pas
elle a passé des heures à appeler à
l'aide elle disait être exténué elle
suffoque et elle avait des vertiges et
personne ne l'a secourue elle a agonisé
est morte dans des conditions
insoutenables
l'amour de ce tournage tout a ému tout
un pays
il marche de soutien à la victime a été
organisée ce vendredi à louga les
manifestants dénoncent les cas
récurrents de mon insistance dans les
hôpitaux publics sénégalais
même pas de moi mon petit fils est tombé
malade la nuit là la maladie de la spin
que je l'amène à les gens c'était un
samedi matin les premiers me dit il
fallait atteindre 20 de plus que jamais
le bon jour et ça c'est normal ce que
nous réclamons c'est dans les deux sens
c'est pour la population un meilleur
accueil des meilleurs soins une
meilleure considération de leurs
conditions de vies humaines on a aussi
réclamé en plateau médical meilleur le
ministre de la santé a reconnu j'ai dit
devant la presse que le décès de la
jeune femme aurait pu être évité nous
sommes bien conscients qu'il reste des
efforts pour humaniser les structures 5
à
la prise en charge des patients demain
pour que des préoccupations un accent
particulier doit être mis sur le
renforcement la formation du personnel
de santé surtout en ce qui concerne la
paix dans les structures
une pétition en ligne pour mettre fin
aux violences subies par les femmes dans
les ou plutôt sénégalais a recueilli
plus de 80 mille signatures en quatre
jours
passent à la culture et je vous emmène à
abidjan pour la première étape de la
tournée africaine de l'exposition
memoria pour plus de quatre mois
quatorze artistes et créatrice
africaines vont être exposés et à
travers elles des récits nouveau pour
déconstruire le beau le féminin et le
traditionnel reportage de samuel bernard
un musée d'art contemporain en plein
coeur d'un des quartiers les plus
déshérités de la capitale ivoirienne le
muc à tavaux bo est l'occasion pour les
enfants du quartier de changer
radicalement de décor alors on y va on
voit quoi dubois est elle tout ça c'est
l'artiste qui les a créés elle aura mis
des parures elle a tout dessiné elle
même nadine au patin est l'une des deux
femmes à l'origine de cette exposition
pour elle faire cette visite a pour but
avant tout de sensibiliser le public à
l'art c'est très enrichissant pour moi
parce que sondés voilà c'est un oeil
neuf et puis on n'a pas du tout les
mêmes référentiels donc c'est assez
surprenant parfois mais c'est toujours
enrichissant fois c'est la notion de
partage qui est la plus importante
qu'elle que soit d'où on vient et quel
que soit son niveau de culture de
connaissance du monde de l'art
de la sculpture de la peinture du
textile et bientôt de l'art vivant
depuis le 7 avril l'exposition memoria
propose une diversité d'oeuvres
appartenant exclusivement aux femmes
artistes du continent
l'occasion pour le public peut découvrir
un pan peu valorisé de la culture
africaine
je connaissais par exemple n'a pas les
idiots
elle a poussé la vie de notre mister
isaiah c'est ça et je la connaissais
mais pas savait pas quand on était
beaucoup abidjan est la première étape
africaine de cette exposition itinérante
à chaque escale ce sont les artistes du
pays hôte qui sont mises en avant la
sculptrice karine manceau est l'une des
six participantes ivoirienne
rêver le temps d'inspirer et de faire
rêver des ivoiriens et les ivoiriennes
l'exposition sera ouverte jusqu'au 21
août le prochain pays hôte reste lui
encore à définir
et c'est ainsi que nous refermons sur
mal l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui nous
ont suivis de brazzaville à abidjan en
passant par louga rester avec nous car
l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]